افادت اذا وكاله مهر الايرانيه بمقتل
اثنين من كبار مستشاري الحرس الثوري في
الغاره الاسرائيليه على حي المزه في دمشق
فيما قالت وسائل اعلام سوريه ان اربعه
اشخاص قتلوا في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف مبن
من اربعه طوابق في منطقه المزه بالعاصمه
دمشق وافادت مصادر للجزيره في دمشق بان
المبنى المستهدف الموجود بالقرب من شعبه
الامن السياسي قد انهار بشكل كامل وقد
اشارت وسائل اعلام سوريه الى ان القصف
استهدف شخصيه مهمه دون تحديد
هويتها للمتابعه معنا الان شبكه مراسلينا
من ادلب مراسل الجزيره صهيب الخلف من
طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد القادر فايز
ومن رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري ارحب بكما وابدا مع عبد القادر
فايز وما اعلنته وكاله مهر عن استهداف
ومقتل اثنين من قاده الحرس الثوري
الايراني يمكن ان نقول بان اننا تحدث عن
اثنين حتى الان حقيقه ازدهار لماذا لانه
حسب المعلومات لدينا بان ما تم استهدافه
في حي المزه في سوريا هو ما وصف بخليه
ربما استخباراتيه وليست بالضروره ان تكون
فقط مكونه من عناصر من الحرس الثوري لذلك
نستطيع ان نقول بانه من المرجح ربما ان
نسمع اخبار جديده في هذا الاطار ولكن
رسميا حتى الان يمكن ان نقول بان هذه
الغاره في حي المزه في سوريا ادت حتى الان
الى مقتل اثنين منم يصفون بانهم كبار
لمستشارين الحرس في سوريا ماذا يعني هذا
المصطلح حقيقه ازدهار مستشار للحرس الثوري
في سوريا هو يعني باننا نتحدث غالبا عن
ضباط برتب عاليه وذو خبره واسعه ربما
بالعمل العسكري والاستخباراتي ونتحدث عن
مستشارين في العمليات بمعنى انهم مستشارين
عسكريين ميدانيين مباشره وكذلك عن
مستشارين في الحيز الاستخباراتي ما الذي
ضربته اسرائيل حقيقه في هذه المنطقه في
المزه في سوريا حتى الان يبدو غير واضح
ولكن المصادر هنا ترجح بانه ضربه في مساحه
الاستخبارات بالدرجه الاولى وليست في
مساحه الميدان ربما لذلك يمكن ان نقول بان
ايران تتحدث الان عن اختيال الاثنين من
المستشارين الايرانيين العسكريين على
الاراضي السوريه في هذه الضربه وهناك ايضا
كلام غير رسمي بان هذه
المنط المبنى المستهدف كان يضم ايضا عناصر
اخرين من جهات اخرى مما تصفه بمحور
المقاومه هذا مصطلح يطلق على حزب الله
وعلى الجهاد الاسلامي وعلى حماس وعلى كثير
من التنظيمات الموجوده في مساحه الاقليم
والتي ربما تلتقي مع ايران فيما يخص موضوع
محور المقاومه حقيقه هي ضربه مباشره
ازدهار ايران قالت سابقا وبشكل الواضح
سياسيا وعسكريا بانها تتعامل مع الساحه
السوريه وفق مصطلح كبير تسميه بالصبر
الاستراتيجي في التعاطي مع هذه الساحه اذا
ما وصفت بانها ساحه متقدمه من ساحات محور
المقاومه يبدو بان اسرائيل تضغط بشكل كبير
جدا ازدهار على عصب ربما الصبر
الاستراتيجي الايراني في المنطقه انطلاقا
من اختيال متتابعه متعدده ضغط مباشر على
هذا العصب ما الهدف من كل ذلك على الاقل
ايران تقول بانها عمليه استفزازات كبيره
ربما لدفع ايران للدخول بما تسميه ايران
مغامره ولكن هل ستدخل ايران حقيقه حلبه
الملاكمه علنا مع اسرائيل في مساحات
الاقليم هذا غير مفهوم حقيقه حتى الان
ولكن اريد ان اشير ايضا الى ان الاعلام
الايراني يربط بشكل مباشر ما بين الضربه
في اربيل قبل ايام وبين الضربه في حي
المزه في سوريا ويقول بان خس سرت اسرائيل
رجلا مهما في الموسات في ضربه اربيل اليوم
تنتقم من ايران بشكل مباشر في ضربه حي
المزه في دمشق ضرب ضربات وضربات مضاده
حقيقه في المساحات الرماديه بين
الاستخبارات الايرانيه
وا الاسرائيليه في مساحات الاقليم ولكن هل
هذا كله يؤشر الى ان ايران مستعده للذهاب
الى ما يوصف بالحرب المفتوحه حتى الان ما
نسمعه في طهران لان السقف الاستراتيجي
لايران استمرار هذه الضربات ولكن دون
الانزلاق الى تصعيد مفتوح فيما يخص حرب
واسعه ومفتوحه في الا